as many of you know donald trump's
personal lawyer
rudy giuliani has once again re-entered
the spotlight
because of his role in the recent new
york post story
more and more of which is being debunked
daily and one of the speculations about
rudy giuliani for a while it's been
written about for a long time not
something i came up with
is that rudy has a serious drinking
problem and that in particular
there was an effort to keep rudy off of
nighttime television because that then
it was more likely that rudy giuliani
would be drunk and that yeah sure
the afternoons could be tough because he
would you know maybe have a few too many
with lunch but that the night time was
really really the problem now i won't go
back through all of the archives but
we've seen clips
before of rudy giuliani showing up
slurring
one eye half shut one day half his hair
was was like shaved he had like shaved
half of his head
maybe it was just a combing issue uh
crooked glasses shiny eyes
red eyes that you know the entire thing
anyway
donald trump's other former lawyer
michael cohen
went on msnbc and straight up said rudy
giuliani is drunk all the time
and it's not speculation it's based on
what i
meaning michael cohen has seen take a
look i mean
rudy is rudy's drunk all the time which
is a big problem
and that's what makes him susceptible
because his faculties are gone
he behaves and i have to ask crazy
are you sharing an opinion are you
sharing an observation like you've seen
him
drink x amount that's the same thing an
investigator would have i've seen no
i've seen i've seen him drink to the
point like he's a
high school drunk um and it makes him
susceptible
and he takes the information that he
gets and he provides it off to the
president
and simply because rudy who used to be
considered
you know a i mean a real a real
litigator and he was considered to be
america's mayor
is now really just a joke the one thing
there
that we of course know to be true is
that rudy giuliani is now considered to
be a joke but that's not actually what's
relevant here
and to be really really careful this is
not
haha rudy is an alcoholic this is about
yet another person who has a direct line
to trump
and is directing much of the opposition
stories
trying to help trump he is allegedly
heavily influencing this and we are
learning that his state of mind and
actions
may be affected by drugs that make you
make bad decisions if you go to counter
intelligence 101
one of the things any good operative
knows
is when an individual would be
susceptible
to alcohol or other substances uh to
disinhibit them in ways that could be
advantageous to an adversary if you're
working a target
you would of course know this rudy
admits
that it's a 50 chance he was working
with a russian spy
on the old the eventual new york post
story we know rudy was a big factor in
pushing for the story to be published
despite the hesitations
that we learned about yesterday thanks
to the new york times
by new york post staffers who were
saying i don't think we should even be
publishing this
this is exactly how people get taken
advantage of by
professionals now the counter to this
would be
let's not just say it's alcohol's fault
rudy giuliani is a wealthy privileged
man with a working brain
who is choosing not only to work for
trump but to continue working for donald
trump and while
the individual action might be affected
maybe by his alcohol consumption if you
believe what michael cohen says
the you know giuliani has agency here
and um he is a uh willing participant
rudy giuliani's daughter who is
supporting joe biden has written about
rudy is choosing to do this you can't
just say it's the alcohol it can be both
that judy
that rudy rather is of course complicit
but open to being taken extra advantage
of
because of the drinking that many now
have alleged also interesting by the way
from that interview i showed you is from
an ari melber
interview on msnbc
one of the other things that michael
cohen said is that
chris christie's debate prep for trump
included suggesting trigger biden
stutter by interrupting a lot it'll make
biden stutter and he will look bad this
has been denied by chris christie
seems totally plausible uh and it is it
is merely an
allegation uh but as far as the
drunkenness thing if michael cohen were
making this up rudy could sue him
and rudy's not going to sue him and
there's every indication michael cohen
is telling the truth because it's what
anybody who's seen rudy on tv
particularly the nighttime appearances
would suspect more sad than anything
is i mean listen alcoholism is a health
issue
what's particularly sad is that
individuals
who may be um in vulnerable states
because of their substance abuse are
being deputized
to drive main narratives primary
narratives
um in the trump smear campaign against
joe biden and that's uh that that's
pretty ugly stuff